-I'm so happy to see you
in person.
-Me too.
-Welcome back.
-And all these beauties.
-And all these humans.
Isn't that great?
-Oh, my God.
-Doesn't that feel good?
You're back.
You're back in New York.
You're back in the U.S.
-Yeah.
-You were just in Colombia.
-Yeah. Forever.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Real time, three months.
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
We shot the first half
of the movie in Bogota,
which is a big city.
Really fun. Great restaurants.
And then we moved to the jungle
for the second half
of the shoot.
-Yes.
-I lived in a house
with two birds.
-You lived with them?
-I lived in the birds' house
is another way to put it.
-So the birds actually --
you met a bird that had a house?
-"Could I stay here?"
-Air Bird 'N' Bird.
-Oh!
-Not bad, huh?
Not good, either.
But Airbnb.
-Yes.
-I'll work on it.
I'll work on it.
-And the first couple of days
that I'm there,
I drop my stuff, I'm working,
and in the middle of the night,
I just heard a lot
of loud squawking.
-Yeah.
-And I just sort of thought,
"I'm in the jungle now."
-Yes.
-Like, you know.
-Get used to it.
This is what it is --
the jungle.
-But by the third day I was
like, "This squawking is crazy.
It feels like
they're in the walls."
And sure enough, I walk -- I do
some exploring around the house,
and I walk around the side of
the house and built
into the house is a bird cage
with these two beautiful macaws,
like these large,
colorful birds.
-Ooh.
-These birds are in a cage
built into the side
of the house.
I'm like, "What's happening?"
-Wow.
-"Was I supposed to be feeding
the birds?"
Like, it was sort of weird.
So, I find --
The woman who works at the house
comes over and she says,
"Well yes, the birds live here.
This is their house."
-Wow. I didn't know.
-And I was, like,
"Let them out."
-Yeah.
-Like, I'm going to be staying
at the house for six weeks.
I'm like...
-I'm staying at their house.
-Yeah, and I've imprisoned them?
-Yeah.
-So as she's opening the cage
to let them out, I'm like,
"Well wait, are they dangerous
at all?"
-Yeah, do they bite?
-And she's like,
"The blue one is old.
He has one eye. He'll probably
stay away from you.
But don't get too close
to the red one or it'll --"
[ Clicking ]
-Really?
-And so next thing I know,
this red one, he's up
in my business.
This red one
wouldn't leave me alone.
-You're having breakfast
with the red one there.
-Can we get a tight shot?
This is how I feel about --
-Can we zoom in on Alison's face
there?
-This is my feeling.
What was at first really fun
and exciting.
-Now he's your buddy everyday
and would just come
and eat breakfast with you?
-He was eating food
off my plate.
Well, I'm not going to say no.
I was like, "Please, please.
I'm not supposed to get
too close to you."
"Another mushroom, sir?"
[ Laughter ]
-I know you were in Colombia
filming
with our friend, John Cena.
-Yes, I was.
-How was that?
He's just the most fun.
-He's great. He's the best.
-Have you worked with him
before?
-No, I had never worked with him
before.
-He's funny.
-But we bonded pretty quickly
over wrestling because...
-"Glow."
-...I used worked on a show
called "Glow."
-Hello. Yeah.
-That was about wrestling.
And he used to work on
some wrestling show --
-I can't think of it right now.
-I can't -- yeah.
-I actually wanted to show this
because I follow you
on the socials and you're great
to follow.
-Thank you.
-And you posted this of you
just working out at the gym.
Just take a look at this.
-Oh, yeah.
-Watch Alison Brie.
This is insane.
♪♪
-Come on. Come on.
-Again, go.
Work. Work.
-Now, here's why I love this.
Not only is it impressive --
not only is it impressive,
but I asked Alison, I go,
"Oh, so you do a lot of
the stunts on -- in this movie?"
And you go, "I don't really do
many stunts."
And I go, "What is that?
'Cause that's intense."
-I was just gearing up to meet
John Cena.
-Yeah, you can't mess around.
-You know, I just wanted to --
Yeah, most of the movie,
I'm just, like,
running near John Cena
and I wanted to be a baddie.
-You are a baddie.
Yeah, you're fantastic.
-I had to gear up.
-All right.
Let's talk about "Roar."
-Yes.
-I'm very excited about this.
It's an anthology series on
Apple TV Plus.
Can you set up what's happening
in "Roar"?
-Yes, it's eight episodes,
eight different stories
and they're all a little
surreal, a little darkly comic
feminist fables, if you will.
-Yes.
-My episode is called "The woman
who solved her own murder."
And it is a feminist take on
the classic male detective genre
as seen through the eyes
of the woman who was murdered.
-Yeah.
-Who I play.
-So you're a ghost in --
-I'm a ghost.
-So I want to show everyone
a clip.
Here's Alison Brie in "Roar."
Take a look a this.
-Patrol just dropped this off.
They're sitting in a car about
half a mile away,
registered to a --
-Rebecca Moss.
-That's me.
-Wow, that's her.
-Can we take a minute to
acknowledge
the real tragedy here?
I was clearly in my prime.
-You think ID'ing a dead girl
is funny?
-No. No.
It' just -- who gets to blowout
and contours their face
before a trip to the DMV?
-Wow. You live with your license
photo a long time, Carol.
-Okay.
-Unless you die.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You actually really do.
Alison Brie, everybody.
All episodes of "Roar"
are available April 15th
on Apple TV Plus.
Alison Brie!